on day one
i'm gonna send the legislative
immigration reform bill to congress
to provide a road map to citizenship for
11 million undocumented
immigrants take immediate action to
protect dreamers restoring refugee
admission raising the target to a
minimum of 125
000 people a year in my first year
wow uh admissions huh biden has pledged
joe biden has pledged to undo
all of president trump's immigration
policies and this weekend he had a call
with mexico's president
on opening the borders yeah all of this
is happening right now
as new migrant caravans are forming in
honduras in anticipation of
joe biden's inauguration and the
implementation of his
new policies more legion policies
joining us right now a man who
just wrote about this john daniel
davidson political editor at the
federalists
john what do you think joe biden's
immigration policies will look like
because believe it or not
he's trying to break something that
seems to have been fixed
that's right joe biden's been pretty
clear that he wants to loosen
president trump's more strict
immigration policies and border control
policies
and that's everything from covet 19
precautions
to asylum processes to
programs like remain in mexico that have
really helped deter
border crossings over the last year or
so
just talking about relaxing these
restrictions whether or not biden
actually does it
will trigger caravans it will trigger
increased numbers of people trying to
get across the border and we're already
seeing that in central america
you report that there's less fear about
the coronavirus
and with the uh hurricanes slamming a
beleaguer those
beleaguered nations those triangle
nations they're making their
their march again and we're already
seeing changes at the border
well that's right and what we're also
seeing is that smuggling networks that
profit
off of illegal immigration hundreds of
millions of dollars a year
at least by charging central americans
for passage north over the rio grande
and into the united states
they are using biden's election as a
marketing tool
promising people that they will be able
to get into the united states
more easily now that biden is going to
be president and that
now is the time to come north and that's
why we're seeing these caravans form
and that's why we're about to see uh a
sharp increase in illegal immigration on
the southern border
so so you remember the uh catch and
release policy
remember any kid could not be a child
who came across the border
we don't know with whom we don't know if
they're parent they can claim whatever
they want
they have to be released into the
country we had kind of solved that
problem
thanks to mexico this socialist
president working tight
with our president put his marines at
their southern border
and has a remain in new mexico at our
southern border
it worked and part of the reason it
worked is because trump
tied trade policy to border policy
mexico's president and the mexican
elites care about
trade more than anything they don't want
to do anything that upsets trade with
the united states
and they showed that they were willing
to cooperate with the united states on
border control
uh in exchange for having trade run
smoothly and the trump administration
was very clever
in connecting those two things uh but
keeping that cooperation and keeping
that partnership going is going to have
to be something that both countries want
to do
and the biden administration doesn't
want to do that
yeah my hope is with everything on
biden's
plate if he does take over and there's
no
last-minute change by the supreme court
that he would say i don't need to create
this problem
the president solved it for now maybe
he'll address that down the line
i'm not uh i i do have that small bit of
hope john thanks so much
thank you all right meanwhile we
continue
what concerns do president trump's
immigration officials have about
biden's open border policies and what
are the price we're paying right now
the guy at the border mark morgan acting
commissioner of u.s customs and border
protection
joins us right now mark what's changed
since the election
so your previous guest is spot on ryan
what what i would add is that the bot
administration doesn't want to just
loosen the incredible successful
immigration policies and strategies by
the trump administration
he wants to obliterate it and his
immigration strategies aren't
immigration strategies
it's an open border strategy and your
previous guest outline he's spot on
look it's not that it will uh create
additional flow it's already started
look latest caravans we have intelligent
shows that they're creating facebook
pages
using whatsapp to talk about openly
about that
under the obama administration our
borders will be open hurry up and get
there
illegally no problem you're going to be
allowed in never to be heard from again
the numbers are skyrocketing we're
between 23 to 2 500 per day
you know those are absolute crisis
numbers and real quick mind the reason
why it's not a crisis now is it's as you
explain
because the cause we have in place we're
able to address it you remove those as
president
as biden wants to do you're going to
have a chaos and a crisis
immediately i mean the you guys also
create great relations with the triangle
nations as well as mexico
and things are settling down you've
built 450 miles of wall
you have enough money for 700 plus miles
of wall 1400 finishes it off
this year you got 1.3 million to
continue
any indication mark that the new
administration coming in will see the
wisdom of finishing the job
right i hope so and look what where
there was an interview today
with with uh uh mr biden a reporter
asked about
that what he promised american people on
the immigration side of the house
and look he's already walking back what
he promised he's gonna do
on day one now
mark hold on i'll i'll play that for you
right now
let's listen please i've already started
discussing these issues with the
president of mexico
and our friends in latin america i will
accomplish what i said i would
do a much more humane policy based on
family unification
but it requires getting a lot in place
and requires getting the funding to get
in place
including just asylum judges it's going
to take not day one it's going to take
probably the next six months to put that
in place
hey you used to work for president obama
read between the lines there what's he
saying
oh he's saying look he's not going to do
what he promised he was going to do on
day one
he's been very clear all along during
the campaign and what what all he was
going to do to undo
day one but he knows he can't do that
because he will create
an immigration crisis that will pay our
comparison
within his first few weeks a good thing
is that means his
transition team is listening to the
experts of cbp
that are warning him he cannot do what
he promised to do on day one or it's
going to lead to a crisis but but we
can't celebrate here because
all he did he's not changing his
policies so all he did was kick the
crisis can
down the road a few months but mark my
words as long as his open border
strategies remain in place
to npp and the other and stop
deportations
we're going to have a crisis he's just
delayed it a little bit brian
they follow our news like uh as soon as
we break it they're all over it and they
react to it
that's one thing i've learned in
following you and i saw the crisis
you guys couldn't put tents up fast
enough to house all the incoming illegal
immigrants coming to our country
you finally got it under control it must
be just breaking up to see
it might be all going backwards but mark
thanks so much appreciate the work
you've done
appreciate the conversations we've had
thanks ryan